alles muss schnell gehen an diesem Tag
wir sind unterwegs mit der ukrainischen
Armee an der südlichen Front
von nicolajev ausfahren wir Richtung
hashorn vorbei an verlassenen Dörfern
jetzt sind hier fast nur
Militärfahrzeuge unterwegs
wir hören Artilleriefeuer am Horizont
schlagen Raketen ein
vorbei an Panzersperren geht es zu einem
der Posten unweit der russischen Linien
damit sie es verstehen wir können euch
auf keinen Fall unsere ganze Position
zeigen wir zeigen nur das was sowieso
von der Straße zu sehen ist auf der
Autos fahren und auf der Kontrollen
durchgeführt werden
ich kann nur sagen dass auf dem ganzen
Gebiet um Herr Sonne herum unsere Leute
sind
ich bin mal ganz bescheiden überall sind
unsere Leute wie viele genau kann ich
nicht sagen das ist ein militärgeheimnis
in den Schützengräben sagt Andree sei es
am sichersten die Stellung ein Teil der
Gräben haben die Russen angelegt am
Anfang des Krieges standen sie kurz vor
nikolaijev die Ukrainer konnten sie
zurückdrängen Satan der Anführer der
Truppe führt uns zum Lager
nachts gab es Beschuss jetzt versuchen
die Soldaten Kräfte zu sammeln
viele haben sich zu Kriegsbeginn
freiwillig gemeldet aus dem ganzen Land
sind sie hierhergekommen um zu kämpfen
sie glauben fest daran die Russen
dauerhaft zurückdrängen zu können
nein warum sollen sie zurückkommen wir
werden das nicht zulassen sie haben nur
einige Schützengräben gebaut und selbst
das nicht komplett das ist überwiegend
von uns wir haben das alles überdacht
in den letzten Monaten haben sie einige
Kameraden verloren aber niemand hier
lässt das zweifeln sie werden
weiterkämpfen
um sie aus der Ukraine zu vertreiben
damit das Leben besser und stabiler wird
ist das möglich
klar ist das realistisch wir haben keine
andere Wahl
15 bis 20 Männer sehen wir im Unterstand
satan ist ein erfahrener Soldat der im
Donbass gekämpft hat und jetzt versucht
hier mit seinen Truppen bodengewinne
gegen die Russen zu erzielen
letzten Monat bin ich 32 Jahre alt
geworden mein Name ist Pedro mein
Rufname ist Satan noch aus dem Krieg im
Jahr 2016 im Jahr 2020 war ich zweimal
im Fronturlaub aber es hat mich zurück
zu den Jungs gezogen ich möchte mein
Leben dem Dienst für das Vaterland
widmen
kampfname Satan darauf ist er stolz die
Russen hätten ihn so genannt erzählt der
uns während die anderen sich ausruhen
bereitet er das Mittagessen vor
zum Frühstück habe ich geschmorte
Kartoffeln gekocht zum Mittagessen koche
ich Borscht ich bin hier der Koch der MG
Schütze und wenn die diensthüren weg
müssen übernehme ich die Pflichten des
kontrollpunktkommandanten
ein Kommandant der alles macht
Soldaten die mit 80 Jahre alten Gewehren
ihr Land verteidigen sie sind angewiesen
auf Unterstützung und natürlich hören
wir von Andre auch die Forderung nach
Hilfe aus dem Westen
wir brauchen möglichst viele Waffen in
möglichst kurzer Zeit dann können wir
diesen Krieg schnell beenden und ich
möchte daran erinnern dass die Ukraine
nicht nur das eigene Land die eigenen
Frauen verteidigt sie verteidigt Europa
als Ganzes vor der russischen Invasion
wenn Sie die Ukraine hätten problemlos
einnehmen können während Sie zu 100%
weiter nach Europa gegangen
solche Explosionen wären dann in Polen
in Deutschland und in anderen
zivilisierten demokratischen Staaten zu
hören
ich möchte daran erinnern dass
russisches Gas nach Blut riecht
Blut von kleinen Kindern von wunderbaren
Frauen der Ukraine
niemand darf das vergessen
weiter geht es in eines der Dörfer das
unter russischem Dauerbeschuss liegt
André und damit die ukrainische Armee
bestimmt an diesem Tag was sie uns
zeigen was wir filmen dürfen wen wir
treffen
so wie dieses ältere Ehepaar obwohl fast
alle anderen das Dorf verlassen haben
sind sie geblieben mitten im
kriegsgebieta
sie schießen die ganze Zeit tagsüber
nachts mal viel mal wenig wie Sie es
wollen es ist normal das wichtigste ist
sie treffen nicht ansonsten sollen sie
schießen es ist schließlich Krieg
sie nimmt uns mit ins Haus die ganze
Zeit ist in der Ferne Artilleriefeuer zu
hören ob sie keine Angst hat will ich
von ihr wissen
wie soll man hier keine Angst haben
natürlich haben wir Angst große Angst
aber wir müssen die Angst ein Stück
überwinden sie beherrschen sie haben
doch auch Angst angeschossen wird
wenn der Strom funktioniert lässt sie
die Waschmaschine laufen gerade backt
sie Kuchen für die Soldaten Alltag im
Krieg
wenn die Einschläge nicht zu stark sind
setzen wir uns auf den Stuhl bei starken
Angriffen öffnen wir die Kellertür und
klettern da rein
das hier hat lubov schon oft gemacht sie
und ihr beinamputierter Mann
sie zeigt uns Ihren Keller
hier in der Mitte ist es sicher
zumindest haben wir das Gefühl dass es
sicher ist aber wer weiß das schon hier
schlafen wir dort ist eine Kerze für den
Fall dass es keinen Strom gibt wenn
andere Menschen ausgeborgt werden laden
wir Sie zu uns ein sie schlafen dann
auch hier bis sie evakuiert werden
die Kellerregale sind gut gefüllt
Eingekochtes Obst Gemüse Konserven
verhungern sagt luboff werden sie nicht
wir haben eine Ziege wir haben Hühner
wir bekommen Lebensmittelpakete wir
hatten schon immer Vorräte das haben wir
uns noch zu subjektszeiten angewöhnt
Vorräte anzulegen so kommen wir durch
zum Abschied gibt es selbstgemachten
Saft draußen sind es 39 Grad da müssten
wir etwas trinken erklärt uns luboff
Gastfreundschaft Austausch mit Menschen
das ist dir wichtig
warum sie und ihr Mann hier bleiben will
ich zum Abschied von ihr wissen
warum weil es unser Zuhause ist es ist
unser Haus unsere Festung wenn die
Soldaten müde und erschöpft von den
Schützen Gräben zurückkehren und
jemanden auf der Straße begegnen dann
lächeln sie fühlen sich gebraucht fühlen
dass jemand sich Sorgen um sie macht
entsprechend herzlich verabschiedet sich
André von den beiden
wir sollen weiter wenn wir zu lange am
selben Ort blieben könnten auch wir zum
Ziel der Russen werden erklärt andre uns
er nimmt uns mit an den Ortsrand das
will er uns unbedingt zeigen und das war
eine Schule
es ist das örtliche Gymnasium das
etliche Treffer abbekommen hat
junge Menschen denen die Zukunft offen
steht Schulen auf die russische Raketen
fallen größer kann der Kontrast nicht
werden also das weiß auch André und
deswegen ist er mit uns hier
für sie ist alles ein strategisches
Objekt alles was schön ist Schulen
Krankenhäuser Supermärkte Asphalt auf
der Straße im Dorf all das ist für sie
strategisch geworden
russische Soldaten russische Mütter
das sind alles Menschen die bei sich
nichts tun sie sehen dass der Nachbar
alles schön gemacht hat und wollen dann
dass es dort auch schlecht ist
was will ich von Andre Wissen sagt er
zum Vorwurf von Amnesty International
der lautet die Ukrainer benutzten zivile
Objekte wie Schulen für armeezwecke und
brachten so Zivilisten bewusst in Gefahr
ich möchte sagen dass ukrainische
Soldaten in ihrem eigenen Land sind wenn
wir irgendwo hingehen so haben wir das
Recht dazu sie dürfen uns nicht
vorschreiben wo wir sein sollen im Dorf
in der Stadt in der Schule oder woanders
das zum ersten
zum zweiten wir kennen die Absichten der
Russen und dass sie auf die Schulen
schießen deshalb halten wir uns dort
nicht auf aus Prinzip und wenigstens
etwas zu erhalten damit wir später
weniger wieder aufbauen müssen
auf einige unserer Fragen geht er nicht
ein wie viele ukrainische Soldaten in
der Region sind wie nah sie an Hassan
stehen und ob er wirklich eine Chance
sieht die Stadt zurückzuerobern die
Russen aus dem Süden der Ukraine zu
verdrängen
er führt uns zu einer Truppe die zwei
Haubitzen bedient die Geräte stammen
noch aus Sowjet Zeiten
schwere Waffen sind der wichtigste
Trumpf auf dem Weg zum Erfolg zum Sieg
dank unserer Artillerie und dank unserer
kleinen Spielzeuge hier können wir
gewinnen damit schützen wir die
Infanterie sie hat mir Spielraum und der
Gegner zieht sich aktiv
zurücklegen
Benjamin und seine Leute greifen
russische Stellungen an vor allem den
Nachschub auch er appelliert an den
Westen mehr Waffen an die Ukraine zu
liefern
ja natürlich mehr Langstreckenwaffen
würden nicht schaden Waffen die viel
weiter reichen damit wir die krimbrücke
oder ähnliches treffen
Zuversicht die russischen Angreifer zu
besiegen das hören wir von vielen André
zeigt uns eine Stelle an der die Ukraine
in den ersten Kriegstagen die Russen
zurückdrängen konnten
hier weint Set sehen Sie es ein
Schützenpanzer
Putin hat einmal gesagt wir gehen direkt
in den Himmel und sie in die Hölle
sie sind im Himmel ohne Schuhe die
Schuhe haben sie hier gelassen und sie
sind im Himmel die Elite der
Streitkräfte
dort sehen Sie schon nicolajew das hier
war eine Brigade mit Fallschirmjäger
andre erzählt er uns zwar selbst
Offizier der sowjetischen Streitkräfte
er wurde in Moskau ausgebildet ob er
manchmal daran denke dass hier
vielleicht auch frühere Kollegen von ihm
für die Russen gekämpft hätten frage ich
ihn
Kollegen wie können wir sie Kollegen
nennen wenn sie Kinder töten wenn sie
friedliche Menschen töten
Kollegen lassen sich auf so etwas nicht
ein ich bin weiter im Kontakt mit
russischen Staatsbürgern mit denen ich
zusammen gedient habe die mir untergeben
war
ich kann sagen dass die putinspolitik
nicht unterstützen wir haben einfach
Angst sie sitzen in Moskau oder in
anderen Städten und haben Angst
es gibt viele solcher Menschen in
Russland er hat einfach alle
Oppositionsführer getötet putin ist kein
Diplomat oder Präsident Putin ist
einfach aus
das Unvorstellbare Undenkbare klingt
damit
André wie so viele seiner Landsleute
kann bis heute nicht verstehen dass das
einstige Bruder voll Krieg gegen sie
führt
wir haben sie nicht überfallen sie sind
zu uns in unser Land gekommen ich möchte
betonen wir müssen diesen Krieg schnell
beenden damit wir weniger Verluste haben
sowohl auf unserer Seite als auch auf
Seiten der Russischen Föderation
es klingt wie ein Appell und das soll es
wohl auch sein die leise Hoffnung auf
ein Ende dieses unerbittlichen Kriegs